We turn now to the second of
the foundational doctrines
in copyright law: the
idea/expression distinction.
Every system of copyright
law contains some version
of this distinction.
In US law, its statutory
locus is section 102(b)
of the Copyright
Act, which provides
"in no case does copyright
protection for an original work
of authorship
extend to any idea,
procedure, process, system,
method of operation,
concept, principle, or
discovery." (Some scholars,
such as Professor
Pam Samuelson, argue
that this provision
reaches more broadly
than the idea/expression
distinction,
but I'll put that controversy
aside for the time being.)
In the Eldred case,
which we will consider
in a subsequent lecture, the
United States Supreme Court
suggested that the
idea/expression distinction
is necessary in order
to reconcile copyright
law with the
principle of freedom
of speech embodied in
the First Amendment
of the federal Constitution.
Lots of other examples
of this distinction
can be found in the
law of other countries.
So what exactly is this famous,
fundamental distinction?
It's easy to state, but
surprisingly hard to apply.
The key concepts
are clear enough:
neither ideas nor
facts are protected
by copyright law; only the way
in which an author expresses
ideas or facts is protected.
Simple enough.
Unfortunately, the key terms
-- idea, fact, expression --
are all ambiguous and contested.
To figure out what
they mean, you
need to examine some
applications of the principles.
HERE'S A GENERAL GUIDELINE:
when interpreting and applying
the idea/expression
distinction, try
to avoid attributing to those
terms their ordinary meanings.
Think of them rather
as "terms of art,"
shorthand references to loose
clusters of things that,
for policy reasons,
the law includes in --
or excludes from -- copyright.
Against this backdrop,
let's consider
some of the contexts in
which the idea/expression
distinction arises.
The first such context is
known as the merger doctrine.
Suppose there is only one
set of words that accurately
conveys a particular idea.
In such a situation,
the principle
that ideas are unprotected and
the principle that expression
is protected clash.
Which prevails?
The principle that
ideas are unprotected.
So anyone else is free to use
that uniquely appropriate set
of words with impunity.
Such situations arise
more often than you
might think-particularly the
context of computer software.
But we will wait to take up
those illustrations until
lecture # 3, when we will
consider the various kinds
of works that copyright covers.
The second context is known as
the scenes-a-faire doctrine.
The 1978 case of
Alexander versus Haley
provides a good illustration.
The basic facts of that
case were as follows:
prior to the publication
of Alex Haley's book Roots,
the plaintiff wrote
a similar book
about the history
of her own family
during slavery and about
her own gradual awakening
to the importance
of her heritage.
When Roots was published
and became famous,
the plaintiff brought a
copyright infringement suit
against Haley.
In support of her
claim, the plaintiff
provided a long list of
parallels between her book
and Roots, arguing that Haley
had copied heavily from her.
The court eventually ruled
that, despite the large number
of similar scenes,
Haley had not engaged
in copyright infringement.
One of the grounds on
which the court rejected
many of the
plaintiffs assertions
is that they involved
so-called scenes-a-faire.
Here's the language in which the
court expresses this judgment:
"These are incidents,
characters or settings
which are as a practical matter
indispensable, or at least
standard, in the treatment
of a given topic.
Attempted escapes, flights
through the woods pursued
by baying dogs, the sorrowful
or happy singing of slaves,
the atrocity of the buying
and selling of human beings,
and other miseries are all
found in stories at least as old
as Mrs. Stowe's.
Other examples include
scenes portraying
sex between male slave
owners and female slaves
and the resentment of
the female slaveowners;
the sale of a slave child
away from her family
and the attendant agonies; the
horror of punitive mutilation;
and slave owners complaining
about the high price
of slaves."
All of these images,
the court ruled,
constituted unprotected
ideas, because they
were standard vignettes in the
genre of US slave narratives.
Some more recent, and
perhaps surprising,
applications of this
doctrine of scenes-a-faire
involve photography.
Here too, courts refuse to grant
copyright protection to images
that they conclude are
standard or typical
of a particular genre.
For example in the 2005 case
of Bill Diodata Photography
versus Kate Spade, the
plaintiff contended
that this photograph, which
appeared in an advertisement
for women shoes, was
infringed by this one.
The court rejected
the argument, arguing
that the positioning
of a model sitting
on the toilet with her
feet angled inward,
though "seemingly unnatural,"
was a common trope;
photographing stylish women in
this pose to showcase fashion
accessories was an idea "used
often in popular culture."
Similarly, in the
2003 Gentiu case,
the photograph on the
right side of this slide
was held not to infringe the
copyright in the photograph
on the left side, because, even
if one photographer had been
imitating the other, the
compositional elements they had
in common were "standard
photographic conventions
or devices" and thus
not copyrightable.
Here"s a more straightforward
application of the same general
principles.
Suppose I write and
publish a cookbook --
a collection of recipes
of a particular sort.
Suppose further that I created
some of those recipes myself.
You copy some of my
recipes and include them
in your own cookbook.
Have you engaged in
copyright infringement?
If the recipes that you copied
contain nothing more than
descriptions of
ingredients, quantities,
ways of combining things,
cooking times, and so forth --
in other words, instructions for
creating the dishes in question
-- then the answer is no.
The reason is that
unadorned recipes
are said to be ideas or
"methods of operation"
and thus not subject to
copyright protection.
By contrast, if the recipes
you copied included expressive
embellishments -- for example
descriptions of how the dishes
taste or suggestions concerning
social circumstances for which
they would be appropriate --
then you would be in trouble,
because such things are
considered expression.
Maps have been protected
by copyright law
for a very long time.
But not all components of maps
enjoy copyright protection.
For example, the location
of roads, mountains, rivers,
and political boundaries; the
names of cities and towns;
are all excluded from
copyright protection.
Thus you can copy such things
from someone else's map
onto your own without
running afoul of the law.
This shouldn't be
terribly surprising.
More interesting is the fact
that newly coined place names
are not shielded.
Suppose, for
example, an explorer
surveys a remote
mountain range, selects
names for the hitherto
nameless peaks,
and draws up a map that
includes those new names.
Another cartographer copies
those features and those names
into his own map.
Copyright infringement?
No.
It's sometimes said that
the newly applied names,
although created
by the Explorer,
become facts once applied
to features in the world.
But that can't be right.
By the same logic,
the text of my novel
becomes a "fact"
once it's published,
and I lose copyright
protection for it.
A more plausible reason is
that to recognize copyright
protection for newly created
place names would frustrate
important public policies
-- concerning communication
of geographic information.
Latent in that
rationale is the seed
of a much more general
principle that will
flower in subsequent lectures.
So what aspects of maps do
enjoy copyright protection?
The answer is original
selection, arrangement,
or presentation of individually
unprotected elements.
The net effect is that entirely
conventional maps receive
no protection whatsoever.
Consider, for example,
this screenshot
of a map created by Google of
the sector of Cambridge, Mass.,
that includes
Harvard University.
If I copy it without
permission, as I
have done for the
purpose of this slide,
have I engaged in
copyright infringement?
Probably not, because
it's difficult to locate
in the Google map any
unconventional selection
or presentation element.
We come, finally, to the
tricky case of history.
Perhaps the most striking
effect of the idea/expression
distinction is the
limited legal protection
enjoyed by works of history.
Suppose I spend years
investigating the life
of a little-known politician
-- and then write and publish
a biography of him.
You read my book, and
then, relying on it,
quickly write your own biography
of the same politician.
You're a better writer than I
am, so your book sells better.
I'm angry.
I point out that you could
not have written your book
without mine, and that
most of the story I told,
and most of the arguments
I made, in my book
can be found in yours.
Do I have a copyright
claim against you?
If the things you lifted from
me consists of facts about
the life of the politician,
then the answer is no --
no matter how much time and pain
it took me to ferret them out.
This principle
governed the outcome
of the litigation
between two historians,
arising out of the
close similarity
between 2 biographies
of the Rosenbergs,
who were tried for
treason in 1953.
Because all of
those similarities
were deemed to involve
facts, the defendant
escaped liability.
What if I included in my
biography some speculations,
and the same speculations
appear in yours?
If I have represented my
speculations as facts,
then they too are unprotected.
The rule underlying this outcome
is known as copyright estoppel.
Having depicted an
assertion as a fact,
I am said to be estopped from
subsequently re-characterizing
it.
So, for example, in the Nash
case, the Court of Appeals
ruled that the
plaintiff's contention
in his book the John Dillinger
had not been killed by the FBI
at the Biograph Theater but
had lived on in California
was not protected by copyright,
because the plaintiff had
offered that
contention as a fact.
What if you lift from
my biography, not
a factual contention,
but an historical theory?
Once again, I will lose,
but for a different reason:
historical theories
are considered ideas --
and thus unprotected.
So for example in the Hoehling
case, the Court of Appeals held
unprotected the
plaintiff's assertion
that the Hindenburg
dirigible had
been destroyed by a
member of its crew
in an effort to
discredit the Nazis.
The bottom line is that
an historian should not
expect to get much protection
from copyright law.
If a second historian copies
significant hunks of her prose,
or closely tracks
original ways in which she
has expressed arguments,
she will have a claim.
But if, as in the usual
case, a second historian
free-rides on her research
and lifts facts or ideas
from her books, she
has no recourse.
These examples surely do not
exhaust the various contexts
in which the idea/expression
distinction has been applied
to limit the scope
of copyright --
but they should suffice to give
you an overall sense of the law
in this area.